hoy les vamos a mostrar cómo hacer un
lanzador de proyectiles este lanzador se
diseñó originalmente para una clase en
una escuela de san diego por un profesor
de ingeniería este lanzador tiene varias
partes hablemos de cada una esta parte
está hecha de tres piezas de madera dos
de un pie cuadrado con un grosor de tres
cuartos de pulgada y es madera
contrachapada de roble y tenemos otra
pieza de 5 pulgadas también de madera
contrachapada con un grosor de tres
cuartos primero hablemos de esto esta
pieza tiene varios huecos distribuidos
por cada 10 grados a lo largo de un arco
y tiene un tornillo de 5 dieciseisavos
que podemos quitar y poner para cambiar
el ángulo del lanzador por acá tenemos
otra pieza esta es una pieza de pvc de 2
pulgadas que está atornillada a esta
pieza de aluminio de tres cuartos de
pulgada que a su vez está unida con un
tornillo metálico de un cuarto por
pulgada y media y luego si observan de
este lado
y hay un bloqueo que es un tornillo de
cinco dieciseisavos que hace que la
barra metálica se detenga lanzando la
pelota de ping pong también tenemos un
pivote que es un tornillo de cinco
dieciseisavos y dos pulgadas de largo y
esta pieza metálica es una barra de
aluminio de tres cuartos de pulgada
cuadrada por 11 pulgadas de largo y
después tenemos un tornillo de 5 32avos
que sujeta el resorte el resorte es de
15 32avos por 3 pulgadas y después
tenemos otro tornillo de 5 dieciseisavos
que pasa por este hueco pero está
anclado debajo de esta superficie ahora
echemos un vistazo a la parte interna
aquí tenemos otros orificios este es un
orificio de cinco octavos en el centro y
una pulgada en el exterior el orificio
de una pulgada tiene una profundidad de
un octavo y el orificio de cinco octavos
tiene una profundidad de aproximadamente
media pulgada eso permite que las
tuercas y arandelas
parte trasera de estos tornillos puedan
situarse en esta pieza y así las dos
piezas de madera encajan lo que permite
un lanzamiento de cero grados
y también tenemos dos bisagras de dos
pulgadas y media ese sería el lanzador
empecemos
ok este es el diseño original de nuestro
lanzador tenemos el mecanismo para el
ajuste de los ángulos y cuando jalamos
esto podemos lanzar básicamente así es
como funciona y podemos quitar este
tornillo dejarlo a un lado y bajar esto
para que quede plano entonces lo que van
a necesitar es una sierra para cortar
madera puede ser una sierra circular
también necesitan un taladro para hacer
los orificios una escuadra una como ésta
sirve pero también pueden usar una como
ésta
necesitarán un transportador para medir
los ángulos una lima es importante
también necesitarán una llave inglesa y
algunas otras cosas como un serrucho
desarmadores y brocas para madera
y aquí tenemos una placa de madera
contrachapada de tres cuartos de pulgada
y por acá están todas las partes que
necesitamos como el pvc las arandelas
las tuercas y también tenemos diferentes
tornillos el resorte y la barra de
aluminio entonces empecemos haciendo la
primera perforación que será para el
tornillo de cinco dieciseisavos que
sostendrá el resorte en su lugar ese
tornillo entonces pondremos una tuerca
en cada lado del tornillo y apretaremos
para mantener todo en su lugar aquí
usamos una broca plana de pala de siete
octavos a la que le pusimos cinta en un
cuarto de pulgada para que la
profundidad sea solamente de esa medida
eso nos permite hacer otro orificio pero
ahora usando una broca de 516 aps así
podremos poner el tornillo en la madera
ahora este es un patrón dibujado en la
computadora que usaremos para hacer los
ángulos aquí usamos una broca pequeña de
3 32avos para perforar los orificios
será más fácil perforar orificios más
grandes con una broca de cinco
dieciseisavos que es el tamaño del
tornillo que usaremos así que los
orificios pequeños nos sirven como una
guía para crear esos orificios más
grandes en el lugar exacto ok ahora
vamos a perforar un orificio en el
centro y para eso usaremos una broca de
pala de siete octavos a la que le
pusimos una cinta para perforar un
cuarto de pulgada de profundidad eso
permitirá que la tuerca y arandela
entren en el orificio y para terminar
usamos la broca para madera de cinco
dieciseisavos
ahora vamos a perforar los orificios que
van en la pieza de madera de abajo y que
ayudarán a que las tuercas arandelas y
tornillos de la placa de arriba no
choquen con la superficie de la placa de
madera que tendremos abajo aquí marcamos
los puntos centrales para esos orificios
vamos a usar una broca plana de una
pulgada y perforar hemos un octavo de
pulgada así que marcamos esa distancia
con una cinta
vamos a usar la broca plana de 5 octavos
para perforar el resto aproximadamente
media pulgada finalmente necesitamos
dejar el espacio para que las arandelas
y tuercas no choquen con la superficie
esa es la broca de 5 octavos y
asegúrense de usar la broca más pequeña
después ahora vamos a poner las bisagras
aproximadamente a una pulgada de la
orilla
estas son bisagras de 2 pulgadas y media
de largo con las bisagras hacia arriba
marcamos los centros y ahora vamos a
usar una broca de un dieciseisavo con
una cinta para perforar solamente media
pulgada de profundidad ok ya tenemos los
orificios ahora simplemente ponemos los
tornillos sin apretarlos demasiado y
después vamos a marcar el otro lado
hacemos las perforaciones y colocamos
los tornillos ahora sigue apretamos todo
ahora vamos a cortar la pieza que nos
dará los ángulos es decir la que tiene
el arco de ángulos que nos permitirá
usar diferentes grados este es el último
corte que tenemos que hacer será un
cuadrado de 5 pulgadas y usando la
sierra circular simplemente lo cortamos
muy bien y ahora vamos a lijar la un
poco para limpiar los bordes y podemos
pegar con cinta el patrón que habíamos
impreso primero usamos la broca de 3
32avos para hacer las perforaciones guía
y hacemos todas las perforaciones
y ahora usamos la broca de 5
dieciseisavos para terminar de hacer las
perforaciones y que queden del tamaño
que necesitamos
ok ahí está la parte que acabamos de
hacer y ahora vamos a alinearla y
centrar hacemos unas marcas para alinear
la pieza con todo lo demás y también
para que podamos poner los tornillos
aproximadamente a tres octavos de la
base eso significa que los tornillos
quedarán en el centro de la base y para
hacer las perforaciones usamos una broca
de un dieciseisavo exp haciendo los
orificios aproximadamente una pulgada y
un cuarto después ponemos un tornillo de
una pulgada y media de largo para
mantener la pieza en su lugar y
simplemente perforamos ponemos los
tornillos y los volvemos a ajustar para
asegurarnos de que hayan quedado bien
comprobamos que se mueve y si lo hace
ok ahora vamos a cortar la barra de
aluminio
el lanzador aquí se usó un serrucho de
11 pulgadas para cortar la barra de
aproximadamente media pulgada de ancho
alejamos un poco y ahora vamos a marcar
el centro y vamos a perforar lo usando
una broca de 3 32avos
para crear el orificio guía
y después volteamos la barra y vamos a
alinearla con las piezas que se van a
sujetar de ella como es el pvc y el
tornillo para el resorte entonces vamos
a perforar los orificios para esos dos
componentes ok
aquí estamos perforando los orificios
guía en la barra de aluminio para lanzar
las pelotas de ping pong esa es una
broca de 3 32avos y ahora que ya tenemos
las guías podemos hacer los orificios
más grandes para el tornillo y para el
tornillo de metal es que va a sujetar el
pvc ahora hacemos la plataforma de pvc
vamos a cortarlo a la mitad
usando una prensa y el serrucho y para
que quede bien necesitamos
reposicionarlo un poco ahora el serrucho
siempre deja una superficie irregular
así que la podemos limpiar con una
navaja tengan mucho cuidado cuando hagan
eso para que no se vayan a cortar y
después pueden usar la lija para
suavizar los bordes ahora vamos a marcar
el centro aproximadamente a tres octavos
de la orilla
perforamos y hacemos el orificio final
ahora ensamblamos todos los componentes
vamos a insertar las arandelas y tuercas
arriba y luego arandelas y tuercas por
abajo esto sujetará el resorte después
vamos a poner el tornillo acá y vamos a
insertar el pivote con sus arandelas y
después dos arandelas y dos tuercas y
una arandela de seguridad apretamos todo
muy bien y nos aseguramos de que la
barra de aluminio pueda girar libremente
ahora vamos a poner nuestro bloqueo en
su lugar que es un tornillo de cinco
dieciseisavos con sus arandelas y ahora
vamos a poner la plataforma de pvc que
perforamos y sujetamos con el tornillo
para metales
podemos usar el desarmador para que
quede en su lugar y apretamos ahora
vamos a poner el resorte que lo podemos
colocar usando unas pinzas
y finalmente vamos a llevar nuestro
lanzador afuera para hacer algunas
pruebas hicimos algunas pruebas y
encontramos que la mayor parte del
tiempo la pelota se desvía un poco hacia
la izquierda así que en el siguiente
vídeo haremos algunas modificaciones al
diseño